Ce qui est immédiat et éphémère semble dominer nos vies,
notre économie et notre politique.
Il est si facile d’être happé par le nombre de décisions prises aujourd’hui,
ou par le dernier tweet d'une personnalité en vue.
Il est facile pour les entreprises d’être tenues par les profits immédiats
et de négliger ce qui est bon pour l'innovation future.
Et c’est beaucoup trop facile pour les gouvernements de ne rien faire,
alors que la mer et les terres cultivables sont appauvries,
au lieu de les préserver pour nourrir les générations futures.
J’ai le sentiment qu’à ce rythme, il va être difficile qu’on se souvienne
de notre génération comme de bons ancêtres.
Si vous y réfléchissez, notre espèce a évolué
pour penser l'avenir, pour anticiper les étoiles,
rêver de l’au-delà, semer des graines pour la prochaine moisson.
Certains scientifiques appellent ce pouvoir magique que nous avons
le « voyage temporel mental »
et cela a permis presque tout ce que nous appelons
la civilisation humaine, de l'agriculture à la Magna Carta,
à Internet –
tout cela étant d'abord apparu dans les esprits des humains.
Mais soyons réalistes :
si nous regardons autour de nous aujourd'hui,
il ne semble pas vraiment que nous utilisions assez ce superpouvoir,
d'où la question : pourquoi ?
Ce qui ne va pas, c’est la façon
dont nos communautés, nos entreprises et nos institutions sont conçues.
Elles sont conçues d’une façon qui perturbe notre anticipation.
Je veux vous parler de trois erreurs clés que, selon moi, nous commettons.
La première erreur est ce que nous mesurons.
Quand nous regardons les profits trimestriels d'une entreprise,
ou le cours à court terme de ses actions,
ce n’est souvent pas une bonne mesure
pour savoir si l'entreprise va accroître sa part de marché
ou être innovante sur le long terme.
Quand nous restons scotchés sur les bulletins scolaires des enfants,
ce n'est pas nécessairement ce qui est bon pour leur apprentissage
et leur curiosité sur le long terme.
Nous ne mesurons pas ce qui compte vraiment pour le futur.
Notre deuxième erreur, qui nuit à notre anticipation,
c'est ce que nous récompensons.
Lorsque nous célébrons une leader politique ou une cheffe d'entreprise
pour le désastre qu'elle vient juste de réparer
ou pour la déclaration qu'elle vient juste de faire,
nous ne motivons pas cette leader
à investir prioritairement dans la prévention de ces désastres
ou à diminuer les paiements futurs en protégeant les communautés
des inondations, en combattant l'inégalité
ou en investissant dans la recherche et l'éducation.
La troisième erreur nuisible à notre anticipation
est ce que nous n'arrivons pas à imaginer.
Quand nous réfléchissons au futur,
nous avons tendance à viser la prédiction exacte de ce qui suit,
que ce soit en utilisant des horoscopes ou des algorithmes.
Mais nous passons beaucoup moins de temps
à imaginer toutes les possibilités qu'offre le futur.
Quand l'épidémie d'Ebola est apparue en 2014, en Afrique de l'Ouest,
les services de santé publics à travers le monde avaient des signaux d'alarme
et des outils de prédiction qui montraient comment cette épidémie pouvait s'étendre,
mais ils n'ont pas réussi à envisager qu'elle allait se propager,
et ils n'ont pas réussi à intervenir à temps
et l'épidémie a crû et a tué plus de 11 000 personnes.
Quand des gens dotés de nombreuses ressources
et de bonnes prévisions ne se préparent pas à ouragans meurtriers,
souvent, ils n'arrivent pas à imaginer combien ils peuvent être dangereux.
Maintenant, aucune de ces erreurs que j'ai décrites,
aussi lamentables soient-elles,
n'est inévitable.
En fait, on peut toutes les éviter.
Pour mieux décider pour le futur,
il nous faut des outils qui nous aident à anticiper, à penser l'avenir.
Pensez à ces genres de télescopes
que les capitaines de navires d’antan utilisaient pour scruter l'horizon.
Si au lieu de regarder à travers l'espace et l'océan,
ces outils permettaient de regarder à travers le temps et vers le futur.
Je veux vous partager quelques outils
découverts lors de ma recherche
qui, selon moi, peuvent nous aider en termes d'anticipation.
Le premier outil que je veux partager avec vous,
c'est comme si le long terme se réalisait dès aujourd'hui.
Voici Wes Jackson, un fermier avec qui j’ai passé un moment au Kansas.
Et Jackson sait que
la plupart des modes de culture dans le monde aujourd'hui
dépouillent la terre de la fertile couche de terre arable
nécessaire pour nourrir les générations futures.
Il s’est rapproché d'un groupe de scientifiques,
et ils ont cultivé des cultures de céréales pérennes avec de longues racines
qui stabilisent la fertile couche arable d'une ferme,
évitant l’érosion et protégeant les récoltes futures.
Mais ils savaient aussi
que pour trouver des fermiers prêts à cultiver ces semences à court terme,
ils avaient besoin d'accroître les rendements annuels de ces cultures
et de trouver des entreprises produisant des céréales et de la bière
pour que les fermiers puissent faire des profits aujourd'hui
avec ce qui est bon pour demain.
C'est une stratégie testée et validée.
En fait, George Washington Carver l'a utilisée
dans le sud des États-Unis après la guerre de Sécession
au début du XXe siècle.
Beaucoup ont probablement déjà entendu parler de ses 300 usages
de la cacahuète, de ses produits et de ses recettes,
qui ont rendu la cacahuète si populaire.
Mais peu savent pourquoi Carver a fait cela.
Il essayait d’aider les pauvres métayers d’Alabama
dont les rendements cotonniers déclinaient
et il savait que s'ils plantaient des cacahuètes,
ils enrichiraient ces sols
et qu'ainsi, les rendements en coton s'amélioreraient par la suite.
Mais il savait aussi qu’il fallait que ce soit lucratif pour eux à court terme.
Passons à un autre outil d'anticipation.
Celui-là, j'aime le penser comme celui qui garde vivante la mémoire du passé
pour nous aider à imaginer le futur.
Je suis donc allée à Fukushima, au Japon,
pour le sixième anniversaire de la catastrophe nucléaire,
consécutive du tremblement de terre Tohoku et du tsunami de 2011.
Quand j’étais là-bas, j’ai entendu parler de la centrale nucléaire d’Onagawa
qui était encore plus proche de l’épicentre du tremblement de terre
que la tristement célèbre Fukushima Daiichi, que nous connaissons tous.
A Onagawa, les habitants, en fait,
ont fui vers la centrale nucléaire pour s'y réfugier.
C'était si sûr.
C'était épargné par les tsunamis.
C'est l’anticipation d’un seul ingénieur, Yanosuke Hirai,
qui rendit cela possible.
Dans les années 60, il s'est battu pour construire cette centrale
plus loin de la côte
à un niveau plus élevé et derrière une digue plus haute.
Il connaissait l’histoire du temple de sa ville natale,
qui avait été englouti en 869 après un tsunami.
C’était sa connaissance de l’histoire qui lui a permis d’imaginer
ce que les autres n'ont pas pu penser.
OK, un autre outil d’anticipation.
Celui-ci, j'y pense comme à la création d'un patrimoine partagé.
Voici des pêcheurs de homards sur la côte pacifique du Mexique,
et ce sont eux qui m'ont enseigné cela.
Ils ont protégé leurs prises de homards
pendant presque d'un siècle,
et ils l’ont fait en les traitant comme une ressource partagée
qu’ils transmettent à leurs enfants et petits-enfants.
Ils mesurent avec précaution ce qu'ils attrapent
de façon à ce qu'ils n'éteignent pas la reproduction des homards dans l'océan.
A travers l’Amérique du Nord, il y a plus de 30 pêcheries
qui font quelque chose d'à peu près similaire.
Ils créent des jalons à long terme dans les pêcheries, dits « parts de prises »
ce qui amène les pêcheurs à être motivés
pas uniquement par une pêche maximale
mais par sa durabilité à long terme.
Il y a beaucoup plus d’outils d’anticipation
que j’aimerais partager avec vous,
et ils viennent de tous horizons :
des sociétés de placement qui regardent au-delà du court terme,
des États qui ont libéré leurs élections
des intérêts immédiats de ceux qui financent les campagnes.
Et il va nous falloir rassembler le maximum de ces outils
si nous voulons repenser ce que nous mesurons,
changer ce que nous valorisons,
et être assez courageux pour imaginer ce qu'il y a devant nous.
Tout ne va pas être simple, comme vous pouvez l'imaginer.
Certains de ces outils, nous pouvons les trouver dans nos propres vies,
pour d'autres, ce sera dans les entreprises ou dans les communautés,
et pour certains, c'est la société qui doit les chercher.
Le futur mérite cet effort.
Ce qui inspire mon effort, c'est l’instrument que j'ai partagé avec vous.
Son nom est dilruba,
et il a été fait sur mesure pour mon arrière-grand-père.
Il était un célèbre critique musical et artistique en Inde
au début du XXe siècle.
Mon arrière-grand-père a eu la clairvoyance de protéger cet instrument
à une époque où mon arrière-grand-mère mettait en gage tous ses biens,
mais c’est une autre histoire.
Il le protégea en l’offrant à la génération suivante,
en le donnant à ma grand-mère,
et elle me l'a donné.
Quand j’ai entendu le son de cet instrument pour la première fois,
ça m’a hantée.
C'’était comme entendre un vagabond dans le brouillard himalayen.
C’était comme entendre une voix venue du passé.
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
C’est mon ami Simran Singh qui joue du dilruba.
Quand j’en joue, on dirait un chat en train de mourir quelque part
donc, s'il vous plaît !
(Rires)
Cet instrument est chez moi aujourd’hui,
mais en fait, il ne m’appartient pas.
C’est mon rôle de le guider dans le temps,
et cela me semble avoir plus de sens que de juste le posséder.
Cet instrument me positionne à la fois comme un descendant et un ancêtre.
Il me fait me sentir partie prenante d'une histoire plus grande que la mienne.
Et ça, je crois,
est simplement la façon la plus puissante de réhabiliter l'anticipation :
en nous voyant comme les bons ancêtres que nous voulons être,
les ancêtres pas seulement de nos propres enfants
mais de toute l’humanité.
Quel que soit votre patrimoine,
qu'il soit grand ou petit,
protégez-le
et sachez que sa musique peut résonner pendant des générations.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)